welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of The Last
of Us episode 5 endure and survive an
episode that players of the game were
dreading the most preceded by the
gnarliest bloodbath we've seen on the
show yet this series is so good it's
hard not to feel the same bleakness that
our heroes feel and I honestly don't
feel like making any quippy joke right
now forgive me but what I can do is take
you back through this episode scene by
scene to point out the incredible
attention to detail and things that you
might have missed and a week from today
will be the launch of our new channel
the Deep dive with a deeper
investigatory focus on titles like
everything everywhere all at once please
subscribe over at deepdive NR so we open
in Kansas City on the night Kathleen's
revolutionary movement over through
bedroom and we are thrust into the
horrific violence that insurrections
tend to be the opening shot is a single
red flare fired into the night sky like
celebratory fireworks but a flare is
really designed to be an SOS signal a
beacon as in these revolutionaries are
morally lost their souls Beyond saving
the flare in its smoke Trail also
reminds me of a fungal stock which my
interview with a cordyceps expert said
in some cases can't shoot upward with a
speed of a gun the palobolus fungus
considered one of the fastest organisms
on Earth so think about that in context
of how fast the clickers imploder in
this regime later this episode The Crowd
chants freedom and you fedra and last
breakdown I compared Kathleen to America
after 9 11. the Nazis making lists of
names over their takeover of Europe the
Israelis getting revenge on Nazi doctors
and really what we're seeing here is
January 6 if it wasn't stopped whenever
throughout history and wherever
throughout the world Revenge fueled
violence is Humanity at its scariest one
Venture Soldier has a bullet hole in his
Temple executed the way the South
Vietnamese police chief executed
Vietcong captain in 1968 the famous
photo of the many state changed public
sentiment about who were the good guys
and the bad guys in the war in Vietnam
Henry will tragically do this to himself
which grimly forces us to question
Justice immorality in this
post-apocalypse these insurrectionists
are laughing as they slaughter Federal
soldiers stripping them down hanging
them dragging their impaled bodies
streets they announce
as we see later with Kathleen the trial
is not at all fair and it's interesting
that they code the federal loyalists as
collaborators collaboration normally
having a positive connotation for
community building but in this
short-sighted movements lexicon a form
of evil Melanie lynskey plays Kathleen
with an eerie Suburban calmness as
opposed to the gruff energy female
revolutionaries sometimes have in media
I'm not fedra lucky for you no one here
has to die yeah we could put you on
trial you're all guilty so that's how
that'll go and you'll do some time easy
yikes the way she has already made up
her mind actually Melanie lynskey had an
amazing Twitter thread explaining how
Kathleen is not the coolest or the
toughest person she's the organizer the
planner multitasker and for better or
worse this group listened to the person
with the best ideas of how to get [__]
done now one prisoner gives up Dr
Edelstein who is helping Henry hide pull
up where he didn't say
I swear I told you everything I know of
course you have You're a Rat oh rat
another nod to Hans Landa who in the
glorious bastards opening scene likened
himself to a hawk and Jewish people to
rats giving his take on the Nazi
propaganda that did as much Kathleen's
Lieutenant Perry is played by Jeffrey
Pierce who voiced Joel's brother Tommy
in the game Perry doesn't want to devote
all the men to hunting Henry
door-to-door would take a lot of men and
their other things he's not my seventh
priority Perry
is that what he is to you Kathleen is so
blinded by revenge and she has no real
plan to maintain stability in KC a
blindness that will do all of them in
this episode Henry and Sam in the game
are brothers Joel and Ellie meet in
Pittsburgh they're originally from
Hartford but here the show gives them
more of a backstory in KC and a
connection to Kathleen and her brother
Michael they meet Dr Edelstein in The
Hideaway that Perry and Kathleen will
find seen last episode is he scared yeah
oh he saw a lie I can do about that now
he's scared because you're scared good
advice from this doctor kids often don't
have context of the chaos of the world
and they look to their Guardians for how
to emotionally respond if the parent
panics the kid will panic and I love
that in the Panic of their escape Henry
knew to pack Sam's bag of crayons among
the other Essentials that give me this
kid something to focus on is as
important as food and other supplies
this gives Sam the opportunity to cover
the surfaces with art that reframes the
outside world as a positive place kind
of like the mother and son characters in
the movie in book room where they
transformed their prison into the
boundaries of the entire world and hey
by the way I am wearing our last of us
inspired shirt that you can get from our
merch Partners at nerdriot.shop getting
these is one great way to help support
this channel okay 10 days later tells us
that in the time span from Revolution
night to Joel and Ellie's arrival in
Kansas City and that suburb outbreak is
only a week and a half that is how long
Kathleen's regime lasted Sam's drawings
show Super Saiyan fighting bedress
soldiers so Sam had the same enemy that
Kathleen had he doesn't fully understand
that Henry sold out Kathleen's brother
Michael to fedra and now that's why cap
plane is hunting them and notice how by
this time Sam is now painting an orange
border around Super Saiyan showing how
he recognizes he and Henry are boxed in
the next day Henry says they're out of
food and Sam asked if they kill Dr
Edelstein hitter says probably yes
remembering edelson's advice Henry keeps
Sam feeling confident by painting an
orange superhero mask on his face which
also gives Henry some confidence when he
looks down at his brother taking care of
yourself is important so good thing
geology makes it easy to do geology is a
16-time award-winning personalized
skincare company recognized in hypebeast
birdie Men's Health Esquire and ask men
grooming Awards with over 6 000 5 Star
reviews just take a quick 30 second
diagnostic quiz and geology will create
a simple and effective skincare or hair
care routine customized just for you
with ingredients that are dermatologist
tested proven to work and personalize to
your needs for skin care geology's got
strengthening shampoo and conditioner
and co-wash which will transform your
routine and deliver the best hair of
your life it extends the time between
washes and replaces the need for so many
products so you wash your hair less and
save money more they also offer body
wash lashes and deodorants that are free
of harsh ingredients and smell great for
skincare they be covered from all angles
you can fight acne reduce oil-ness
prevent wrinkles combat dark or puffy
under eyes have smoother hydrated skin
and Target signs of aging their daily
personalized skincare routine comes with
Too Faced washes a morning face cream a
retinol night cream and eye cream and
right now for a limited time you can get
a five piece trial set for only fifteen
dollars if you use code rockstars 70 at
checkout it's over 150 a product for
just 15 on top of that you'll get an
additional bonus offer on one of their
brand new skin hair and body products of
your choice when you add it to your
trial to get started just click the link
in the description as they leave we
realize this is the same moment Joel and
Ellie are crashing through and I love
the point of view work across these two
episodes last episode from Ellie's point
of view we didn't see Joel shoot that
second Hunter and now we do see that
from Henry's point of view and now when
Joel looks over in his Direction Henry
Ducks last episode you can see that same
white door across the street with the
five box windows that Henry was looking
at but at that point we didn't know
Henry was there Henry gives Sam one of
two unloaded guns that he and Edelstein
pointed at each other so if you think
Edelstein left them with that gun had
Edelstein kept that gun he might have
been able to escape from the
revolutionaries or at least to pull them
but when Henry gives his brother the gun
and mirrors what Joel did with Ellie and
he tells Sam to hold it firm but he
doesn't tell him to use two hands that's
something that Sam does on his own which
makes Joel less likely to try anything I
love how Joe refuses to warm his tone
that's right
man that's just the way he sounds he has
an [__] voice Joe tell him he's okay
everything is great dude yeah if you
think about it Joel is intentionally
staying cold for that line everything's
great just to psych out Henry the next
morning Henry gives Joel a view of the
city welcome to killer City
10 days ago no he always heard Casey
Federalists monsters salvages yeah you
heard right making torture to murder
people for 20 years
you know what happens when you do that
to people
and they get a chance they do right back
to you yeah killer city is a nickname
given to KC popularized by rapper Pat
Jones track killer city which did come
out after 2003 but probably would have
been a nickname locals used before then
the fact that Joel had heard of the KC
veterans reputation tells us how
horrible of a life Kathleen and those
revolutionaries must have lived under to
get them to that point Henry says not
officious mean Sam you seem capable
enough your arms are wrong and wrong
never killed anyone and punching an
unloaded gun I choose the closest I've
ever come to being violent yeah Henry's
making a major admission here that their
guns were not loaded so Joel isn't
really pissed he recognizes here that
Henry can be trusted Henry draws them a
map and explains how to cross the
Highway by throwing to Sam who writes
tunnels on his Woody Woodpecker Doodle
Pad and I love this detail because one
it establishes this as how Sam
communicates and two demonstrates the
tunnel route as one a kid like Sam is
not afraid of so Joel and Ellie are more
likely to see it as safe Henry says that
fedra drove all the infected underground
15 years prior and claims that they
cleared it out three years ago and
admits that in the meantime a few more
might have gone down there one of those
blind ones that seems like a bat you ran
into a clicker two of them and you're
still alive yeah I think this is the
first time the show has used the term
Clicker from the game which also signals
to Gamers that they are going to be
following the infected progression from
the game which includes next stage
floaters that plus the fact that he said
it was 15 years since the infected were
bottled up underground tells us that
that's plenty of time for more of them
to bloat as they navigate the tunnels I
love how Joel sounds like a gamer who
has died playing The Last of Us several
times see it's empty the plan is good
plan is good we've been down here two
seconds we don't know anything that's
kind of a pessimistic yes both Ellie and
Joel are on the same page that Joel for
now sees Ellie as cargo still they
reached its entrance that's painted to
look like a happy Kingdom which looks
exactly like the entrance to the
underground Pittsburgh area where Danny
and ish live and inside they find a
kid's drawing of Danny and ish our
protectors just like the one you find in
the game so ish ish was a fisherman who
had been out to sea for several months
during the outbreak and returned ashore
near a Pittsburgh sewer entrance and
there he established a community with
another guy named Danny and Susan and
Kyle and their kids and several others
but at some point a door was left open
and ish and Susan and the kids escaped
and made it out to the suburbs after
that their fate is unknown we see that
hinted at by the rules here and Joel
hint said that I heard about places like
this people went underground after
outbreak day build settlements happened
to them maybe they didn't follow the
rules and they all got infected actually
it's his name was
name which are Stewart's 1949 puts the
popular
bites in which this guy ish leads a
similar community of pandemic survivors
now here in Kansas City ish probably
would not have been a fisherman who was
out to sea but now the uniforms make a
bit more sense make me think that itch
and Danny might have been Badger
soldiers in the show at least who broke
away from the more awful rest of Kansas
City fedra Sam and Ellie find a Savage
Starlight comic this is an in-universe
comic series in the game following Dr
Daniela Starr space Adventurer in 2186
this episode's title endurance survive
comes from the trophy that you get in
the games if you collect all these
Comics which is why Ellie is so stoked
to talk about her collection no way I
love these
have issues four five six eleven
Issue 11 you can find upon leaving
Pittsburgh in the game after escaping
the hunters in Washington shore on the
beach it's in the wrecked boat but she
said she has issue five and issue five
in the game isn't found until way later
in Tommy's damn this issue is accretion
you see the title at the bottom there
that is issue six in which Daniela and
Captain Ryan are thrown into an arena
where the Hostile extraterrestrials The
Travelers make them fight to the death I
guess you could say there's a parallel
in the way that Ellie and Sam are thrown
into a death Arena as Ellie and Sam
recite the endure and survived Creed
from the comics behind them on the wall
the Pats kids drew stick figures of an
older girl and a younger boy that
parallel Ellie and Sam In This Moment
Joel apologized for assuming Henry was
untrustworthy All Things Considered
seems kind of cruel to send the whole
Army after you for that but Henry
doesn't let Joel let him off the hook
he's still punishing himself or
betraying Michael in order to get
leukemia medication for Sam from Pedro
it was a man great man
he's never afraid
never selfish
and he's always forgiving have you ever
met someone like that
kind of man you'd follow anywhere
Melanie lynskey said in an interview
that Kathleen's brother was considered a
Jesus figure and so that metaphor would
make Henry the Judas Iscariot who was
the Apostle who turned in Jesus and in
the New Testament committed suicide I am
the bad guy because I did a bad guy
thing but you get it though
you might not be her father
she was someone's we learned last
episode that Joel has been both a black
hat and a white hat that he previously
faked being injured to lure people into
a trap but it's worth noting that Joel
did not do these bad things to protect
Sarah Sarah was gone at that point he
didn't even have protecting a kid as an
excuse Perry finds Kathleen in Michael's
childhood room where a soccer photo is
still on the wall and she says when
Michael and I were little
this room seemed so big I was really
scared of thunder
so when there was a storm Michael told
me that this wasn't a room at all
that this was actually
it's the big wooden box
a big wooden box that nothing could get
inside of he said
as long as we were together
no perfect box
we would be safe pretty sad for Kathleen
to feel this way even after seeing
salmon Henry's Hideout last episode and
realized that Henry had been doing the
same exact thing for Sam to protect him
but that is the point Michael's death
proved to Kathleen that his forgiveness
his turn the other cheek mindset did not
help him survive this backwards world so
hereby agreeing that they're doing the
right thing both she and Perry are
sealing their moral Fates the others
make it to the suburbs across the
highway but a sniper starts firing on
them Henry tries to run away with Sam
gold what are you doing oh [__]
oh
yeah notice how Henry reacts to The
Gunshot Sam doesn't he just reacts to
Henry tells us how confusing this all
must be for this deaf kid Joel sneaks up
behind the shooter and begs him not to
make him kill him please don't do it
please
yeah interesting again how we cut away
from Joel killing someone the second
hunter that Joel shot last episode that
guy Brian who he stabbed were both off
screen those were only experienced from
Ellie's point of view just like this
killing is here only Joel's pummelina
that fedra soldier in episode 1 do we
see because Ellie sees it Joel's
violence is only depicted when it has a
role in activating Ellie's violence Joel
screams run which at first the kids
don't hear because it's too far away
until it's too late and the plow is
barreling through the cars in two heads
run spray painted on it the tension is
so nerve-wracking especially when the
rifle jams and immediately after it jams
we cut back to the word run on the plow
as if it is Joel's mental scream to
Ellie but that jam provides a pause for
Joel to collect his breath and re-aim so
the next shot he fires takes out the
plow driver Henry asks Kathleen to at
least let the kids go but Kathleen
refuses to accept Henry's argument that
doing anything to save a kid is worth it
but did you ever stop to think that
maybe he was supposed to die kids die
Henry they die all the time
world revolves around him that he's
worth
everything during this morally bankrupt
line which Melanie Linsky delivers
perfectly without an ounce of remorse we
cut to Joel who is doing the same thing
for Ellie their entire relationship with
Henry and Sam is designed to force Joel
to think about his relationship with
Ellie Kathleen believes she is the one
delivering Henry's rightful fate it ends
the way it ends
but Kathleen fails to see her own
rightful fate warned to her last episode
with that pulsing hell mouth back in the
city that Petra didn't really clear all
the infected they just moved them the
burning plow truck has damaged the
basement of this house and that heavy
ass truck caves a hole into the sewers
below and
I love how fast those infected guys are
up out of the hole all at once from
Joel's high angle you can see one of
them running in his Direction still on
fire much like the experience you would
have playing some parts of the game Joel
is stuck on one perch having to shoot
infected to keep Ellie safe in another
area the editing makes it seem like he
and Ellie are starting to share a hive
mind like all the pieces of the fungus
do he sees Ellie looking at an open
vehicle window and his eyes Dart over to
it he's just somehow able to know where
she needs to go and clears a path for
her and then we see it the bloater Rises
up from the pit so bloaters are the
station infected after clickers in which
the fungus continues to build on the
body over 10 years before made a kind of
armor resistant to gunfire and I love
that the show designers kept his sagging
belly like bloaters having the game
though bloaters in the game aren't This
Tall they don't seem strong enough to
lift people in the air like this but
they can totally rip your job hard and
smash your skull Perry gets his
attention and his Kathleen flees we see
it ripping Perry's head off it is wild
and I do love that as is sometimes the
case in the game the bloater is not
taken down the last time we see that
swarming Street the bloater is still
walking around Joel is so shaken by
seeing this bloater that he loses sight
of the one clicker small enough to fit
in that vehicle window a young girl this
clicker is actually played by young
actress Sky Bell cowton who is an
accomplished gymnast Ellie is able to
evade her but when Kathleen catches them
it is that same girl clicker who gets
her bit of irony considering Kathleen
previously considered kids lives
unimportant in the motel afterwards
while Ellie reads the comic to him Sam
looks uninterested because he knows he
has been infected at this point he
writes if you turn gonna do a monster is
it still you inside a similar fear that
Ellie had when she previously asked Joel
about this and then was able to
investigate when she sliced open that
infected in the convenience store
basement but on a deeper level this is
also a thematic question if you start to
act monstrously are you the same human
you once were does our monstrosity come
from some natural external evil separate
from us or do we innately invite the
monstrosity to take us over by some
force of Destiny maybe natural selection
as a result of our natural affinity for
monstrosity that was always inside us so
that we reconnect with nature this is
the sort of question posed by Mary
Shelley's Frankenstein Richard
Matheson's I Am Legend even with Robert
kirkman's decision to title it The
Walking Dead The Walking Dead referring
to the human survivors of that story
ultimately it's human vanity to consider
our souls exceptional above nature and
these monsters are Nature's Way of
rebalancing the status quo we are the
monsters we are legends and that was
always us inside it just you know really
sucks to see this happen to a kid Ellie
cuts her hand hoping her blood will cure
him but it does not work that way and
Ellie awakens to see Sam sitting facing
the sun maybe reacting in the sunlight
same way the infected in episode 2
turned in the sun Henry grabs a gun at
first seems like he's gonna shoot Joel
but then instinctively shoots Sam and
then flooded with despair that Kathleen
might have been right that maybe it
wasn't all worth it he makes the
decision to end it this is mostly how it
goes down to the game and I think it
might have been just too much to change
Henry and Sam's fate because the truth
is yeah this is a bleak world and Joel
for his future path needs to be
conflicted with the possibility that
putting everything on the line for a kid
might not be worth it looking back
giving Bill and Frank a happy ending
episode 3 was desperately needed for
this HBO series because otherwise it
would have been one Bleak suicide after
another Ellie leaves Sam's notepad on
its grave with I'm sorry written on it
and I think what's even sadder for me
the way she wrapped the string around
the top and Tucks it in so that no one
else will ever be able to write anything
else Joel was wrong that it's easier for
kids because no one is depending on them
because kids can sometimes feel their
responsibility too as Ellie did as a big
sister to Sam by trying to give her her
blood to Sam she really thought that she
might cure him and by asking which way
is west she's not burying her grief she
is furious with herself in desperate to
find a doctor who could turn her blood
into a cure to prevent this [__] from
happening ever again and Joel and Henry
were also wrong that endure and survival
was redundant and didn't make sense it
does make sense the two words are
different things to survive is to just
Stave off death but to endure is to
emotionally Harden oneself and to
tolerate the pain of survival and as
these two characters walk this path they
must both endure and survive please
subscribe to the Deep dive you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at EA
boss follow me rockstars And subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
foreign